une femme qui peut séduire n'importe
quel homme qui détruit des couples elle
finit par marier avec un président de la
République
je suis très heureux de vous retrouver
notre invité principale ce soir c'est
Josiane Balasko
salut alors Josiane Balasko bonsoir vous
êtes auteur scénariste romancière
actrice comédienne militante mais
surtout vous êtes celle qui a prouvé
qu'on pouvait devenir une star en
s'appelant Josiane oui ah bah oui là
c'est pas c'est pas évident
et vous êtes la seule Josiane célèbre au
monde en fait
ça vaut un big up
[Musique]
je l'interroge peu dieu merci je suis
pas en train de regarder c'est pas le
cas tout le monde et on le sait ça
s'appelle Salut les Terriens il est
vraiment défense
[Musique]
alors Josiane Balasko rebonsoir
donc vous serez sur la scène du Théâtre
de la Renaissance à partir du 25 janvier
dans la nuit sera chaude une pièce
écrite et mise en scène par Josiane
Balasko avec Josiane Balasko Valérie
langue Daniel berliou Pascal Bongard et
Georges Aguilar alors c'est l'histoire
de Dina qui jouait par Valérie langue
une jeune femme peintre qui est la
maîtresse d'un pilote de ligne marié et
un soir ou ce pilote de ligne se remet
de son jet lag dans son bain une femme
vous Josiane Balasko sonné à la porte et
vous prétendez en fait que ce pilote
c'est Pedro son mari chauffeur routier
voilà oui c'est ça le départ c'est une
grosse menteuse et surtout
Monique Monique
monique a un secret c'est qu'aucun mec
ne peut lui résister
et ça Dina ne le sait pas mais elle va
s'en apercevoir à ses frais d'acheter
son dévolu sur le pilote de ligne mais
alors une femme qui peut séduire
n'importe quel homme qui détruit des
couples elle finit par marier avec un
président de la République
non ce que dit Monique c'est que dans
les premiers temps elle s'est taper tout
le monde et elle ajoute ensuite il y a
quand même 80 % de mauvais coups
d'accord alors dans la nuit sera chaudes
votre mari Georges agilar est également
sur scène vous dites on s'est rencontré
sur le tournage du fils du français en
Amazonie j'avais vu ce qu'il avait fait
dans Bagdad Café je lui trouvais un
charisme extraordinaire c'est un ovni il
est beau il représente la puissance
virile sans agressivité non mais c'est
la vérité ah bah c'est la vérité
en Amérique du Sud mais il est d'origine
Apache alors après le chef indien vous
allez vous taper tous les people comme
ça non
mais je sais pas s'ils sont très portés
sur les femmes non pas trop bah voilà
pas trop c'est vrai que le matin avant
de prendre sa douche il fait une petite
danse de la pluie
non je peux pas rien dire parce qu'après
il va débouler dans le plateau il veut
casser la gueule
n'ont pas besoin d'être agressifs
Georges guilard il aurait pas pu
s'appeler cheval fougueux les Indiens
c'était un peu comme les Juifs en Europe
de l'Est c'est à dire qu'ils avaient des
noms qui étaient les leurs et chaque
pays leur a donné on est tu t'appelles
montagnes noires en hébreu oui on va
t'appeler
voilà et les Indiens pareil Aguilar ça
vient de aigle il a pas de nom d'Indiens
je veux dire
dans une de mes dernières pièces dans
lesquelles il jouait il s'appelait ours
qui n'aime pas être dérangé
alors vous vivez avec un indien donc
d'Amérique vous êtes d'origine
yougoslave vous l'avez trouvé comment le
débat sur l'identité française j'ai
trouvé totalement déplacé on n'a pas de
problème sur ce que c'est que l'identité
française apparemment il y avait que les
mecs du gouvernement qui en avait alors
votre vrai nom c'est Josiane
balaskovitch vous trouviez que ça
faisait un peu joueur de foot
était dans yougoslave votre mère
Fernande était française ils avaient un
bistro restaurant à Saint-Ouen et
ensuite entre la gare de l'Est et la
gare du Nord et vous vous aviez pas le
droit de sortir peut-être parce que
c'était dans les années 60 et les moins
de 10-12 ans ils allaient pas se balader
il restait chez eux et moi j'avais quand
même la chance énorme de de rencontrer
toute la journée des gens bah oui tu
étais coincée chez toi et tu bouffes
avec tes parents j'avais la chance de
pas avoir à bouffer avec mes parents
alors vous dites je faisais mes devoirs
dans un coin de la salle je passais mes
journées à regarder les clients des
ouvriers des poivrons des fauchés des
vieux j'avais conscience d'être
différente je regardais les gens dans
les critiques j'aimais leur poser des
questions est-ce que ça m'a appris c'est
accepter beaucoup de gens toutes sortes
de gens toutes sortes de différence
voilà ça ça m'a appris que que les
personnes sont pas forcément ce qu'elles
ont l'air d'être parce que dans les
bistrots c'est comme une scène de
théâtre le client arrive tu admettons en
scène qui est derrière le comptoir qui
est le patron et ils font leurs entrées
et au bout d'un moment on se confie ils
ont leurs histoires ça vous a appris
l'empathie dire qu'aujourd'hui quand
vous écrivez pour un homme vous êtes un
homme ouais c'est ça c'est une bonne
école
alors à l'époque vous sentiez que vous
n'étiez pas comme les autres et vous
imaginez déjà que vous allez être
quelqu'un d'important mener une vie hors
norme je savais que je voulais pas avoir
de patron je voulais pas avoir quelqu'un
qui me commande je crois que c'était ça
qui me motive alors votre mère était
persuadée que ses enfants étaient
géniaux ce qui est pas fou d'ailleurs
parce que votre frère est devenu un
astrophysicien à écouter et comme vous
dessinez bien elle pensait que vous
alliez devenir ah bah oui un équivalent
pas de Picasso mais presque et alors
dessinez bien mais très mauvaise pour
les couleurs j'étais pas faite pour
devenir un peintre alors votre mère
s'est signé au cas de veines pour vous
envoyer dans la fameuse école de
penningen où on prépare les arts déco et
les Beaux-Arts mais vous avez été recalé
en fait mais ça m'a appris beaucoup de
choses penningen ça vous apprend une
chose c'est à faire charrette c'est à
dire qu'on vous donnait des devoirs à
faire à la maison où on devait y passer
la nuit donc
alors vous avez été recalé dans causer
déco à ce moment là vous savez pas trop
quoi faire et un jour vous accompagnez
votre votre ami Laura lofer chez la
fameuse professeure Tanya Balachova et
là vous restez là vous traînez là oui je
traîne là parce que j'avais envie de
faire du la déco théâtre je me dis bon
je suis un peu dessiné je suis quand
même pris que j'ai des bases assez
solides et mes chimpançait pas du tout
que j'allais faire actrice et le prof
non plus il m'a vu arriver il m'a dit
qu'est-ce que vous foutez là c'est pas
votre place dit je peux rester et
c'était une époque bénie on n'avait pas
besoin de fric pour rester dans un cours
à l'époque la plus les trois quarts des
élèves avait pas qu'il y avait pas le
fric ne payait pas donc je suis resté
jusqu'au moment où je découvert que
éventuellement je pouvais faire rire et
depuis vous êtes drôle bah je sais pas
si je suis drôle mais enfin j'essaye
alors comme disait Coluche vous voulez
faire vedette que vous faites vedette
j'étais la seule d'ailleurs splendide
pour la bonne raison quand on est
vedette on a des grands rôles moi
j'avais envie de jouer beaucoup j'avais
un gros appétit il vous manque que bien
sûr tout le temps qu'est-ce qui nous a
laissé Coluche à part des milliers de
gens à nourrir tous les hivers
pas quand on repense à tout ce qu'il a
dit et tout ce qu'il a fait il a il a
laissé un esprit d'insolence qui
n'existe plus
alors ensuite il y a eu le Café de la
Gare le splendide
vous parlez de quoi comme vous
rencontrez les mecs du splendide du CAC
[Rires]
non on n'a jamais parlé de pognon à vrai
dire sauf quand on en avait pas vous
savez bien que les gens qui ont de
l'argent ne parlent jamais d'argent bien
sûr on n'a pas besoin alors ensuite il y
a eu les pièces les films les romans le
militantisme et c'est vrai
qu'aujourd'hui il y a plus tellement de
comics engagés vous êtes une des rares
aujourd'hui à vous battre pour le pour
les sans-papiers pour le droit au
logement etc comment ça se fait personne
bouge
je sais pas c'est peut-être plus la mode
je me souviens dans les années 70 les
musiciens les faire des concerts de
soutien aux gens en grève c'était des
parties de la culture or maintenant la
culture c'est plus ça c'est devenu
peut-être plus individualiste mais je
pense aussi que les gens aussi ont un
petit peu peur de s'engager qu'est-ce
qui va se passer qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce
qu'on va qu'est-ce que je vais pas avoir
le fils cocu des conneries comme ça que
je peux être sur écoute et alors c'était
sur écoute qu'est-ce qu'ils entendront
tu vois moi j'ai pas peur personne ne me
fera un deuxième trou du cul
je crois que c'était une c'était une
expression de ma grand-mère et je
trouvais ça formidable c'est vrai quand
ça remet si je peux me permettre
l'expression les choses à leur place
donc je veux dire si je dis mes idées si
je les proclame si je gueule un peu
qu'est-ce qui va se passer
malheureusement
je trouve très en forme là
vous avez quand même des bonnes idées de
pitch vous bah je sais où elle va
chercher tout ça j'en sais rien ça
arrive comme ça non non non je fume pas
parce que ça me donne faim
donc je bois légèrement non on devra
même pas c'est comme ça je fume
énormément des cigarettes et je joue sur
mes jeux vidéo pour me calmer mais c'est
toi donc c'est le 25 janvier au Théâtre
de la Renaissance ça s'appelle la nuit
sera chaude et pour être sûr de ne rien
rater de inarritube abonnez-vous et
mettez un pouce bleu